the trend of stolen catalytic converters
continuing right here in las vegas and
really all around the country it is
costing drivers a lot of money and a lot
of time so is a way to stop it from
happening sasha loftis looking into this
speaking with an expert tonight who
shares tips to protect your car and
sasha your wallet
absolutely brian now the way thieves are
getting these catalytic converters out
they're getting under a car like this
and cutting them out and a lot of times
they're able to do it in just minutes
now the expert i spoke with said you can
protect your car but you have to make
sure you're doing it the right way
we try to turn our car on and it sounded
like an explosion elizabeth rose
describes the moment a trip out to eat
turned into an absolute nightmare my
wife's first thought is you know our
catholic converter got stolen that
catalytic converter wasn't just stolen a
man cut it off her car in the middle of
a busy shopping center brings over all
of his tools crawls under the car and
within five minutes he removed it
unfortunately stories like this are all
too common across the valley in 2021
there were 1806
catalytic converter thefts reported in
metro's jurisdiction last year we had a
lot of claims
with a lot of calorie-converted deaths
it's forced many to try different
protection techniques like spray
painting or vin number etching to send a
red flag to buyers but victor bonari of
universal motor cars says this won't
necessarily stop thieves from taking
them doesn't really help because
it's for they sell it for the materials
on site instead he recommends buying a
guard clamp or shield to encase the part
i think that's going to be the only way
to protect it rose says it's also
important to share stories like this so
others know how and when they can help
people just aren't aware of what this is
happening
to get one of those guards or clamps to
protect your catalytic converter on your
car you can find those online they run
anywhere from about a hundred and fifty
to three hundred dollars and you can
have your local mechanic or auto shop
install them for you reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now
sasha